all right so spoiler for the episode I
go mining at some point but yeah I'm an
idiot and was recording the wrong screen
whenever I recorded this intro so I'm
doing this in post what's going on guys
how you guys all doing if you guys don't
know about series I had a pretty shitty
account with one mill a while back and
we've been working at it ever since
I lost two mill in the intro doing some
merging but I'm an idiot didn't record
it so there's a little bit of backstory
for you let's go ahead and get on into
the rest of this [__] having out a
little bit too the alcohol collection
thanks a lot zdenka z-boy oh my god and
here we go gonna go ahead and get
ourselves sixty five or not too bad I
think this is also a fan of the video so
what's going on man and here we are so a
lot of stuffs been going on if you guys
did not watch my video earlier this week
on the holes aura update basically I
lost a decent amount of money on having
an arcane it's not my history anymore
but I lost 20 ml on one we'll just put
it like that last night
the arcane dipped from about 130 to 125
and I was able enough I was like I was I
was pretty lucky and sniping won for 125
or so I thought at the time and I
figured overnight it'd probably go back
up to around 128 so that's where I kept
my offer in and I wake up in the morning
and it is a hundred and yeah what 105 is
what I sold it off for but I've been
investing in Zorah scales as you guys
can see here which is really really nice
oh my god totally forgot to do this but
this was the entire reason I was
recording and that is to show you guys
my total amount of scales that I have
right now it is pretty ridiculous but
there we are
so 1.5 mil scales we have around 171
melon scales I bought all these for
pretty much around 115 116 per one I'd
imagine probably closer to 115 so if I
go ahead and do the math on that that
means in total I spent a hundred and
seventy four mil on all of these so
we'll see how they do it's not too bad
of a merch I think that they should do
really well but we'll see over time but
with that said we're gonna start skill
in questing because I can't do anything
else and there we go client of kuranda
quest done
point along with 20% favor mr. Elias is
what I went forward because I have a
video that I want to make tomorrow that
goes over our money making method there
other than that I really want to start
getting favor up so I can unlock all the
benefits that come with this new
continent of runescape that I barely
ever am on so I've been recording the
wrong screen I missed the level kind of
but I went ahead and got 70 herblore up
to 1601 total on top of that the zora
scale is currently buying for 126 coins
which means I've made 10 coins on each
one pretty much right now so that means
in total we made 15 mil back almost made
back the money for the archein so really
happy about that oh my god people wonder
why I don't train this damn thing we
finally went ahead and got 15 holy [__]
was that quick I did not expect that
finally got 100% miss Crilley is favor
I'm had trouble saying that but this is
kind of what really well because I ended
up getting 1900 to go back to the
Redbirds however I think the green ones
are what's next but now I can go ahead
and make the video that I wanted to make
so we'll figure out where to go from
there probably get some other favor and
here we go time to go ahead and finish
up my chazy and favor got a lock it in
really nice about that though so now we
are up to both jay-z and and Pisco alias
I don't know what else I really want to
do I know I probably need to do his city
it's just to unlock the woodcutting deal
just because that's kind of useful I
guess definitely the shays Ian was
really nice to get I also was able to
get one of these talismans that is
really really cool because I don't know
where all these go I don't know if I
have five charges in here oh I have
exactly five that works out really well
I'm just gonna kind of check out the
place that this takes me to because I
honestly have no clue so this is right
below shady an area which isn't bad I
guess yeah this would probably be a good
yeah I think this is a good teleport to
go ahead and go to raids I think maybe
it's one of the best I'm not entirely
sure so we're just kind of looking
around I have no clue where any of this
takes us this one I mean realistically
there's a house tab like right over here
so that's not all that useful I wouldn't
say number three
oh this one is so nice
oh my whenever I want to go to brutal
blacks oh that is I just teleport here
and run there that is beautiful oh my
god yeah I never never knew about any of
these things man all right I have to
finish something else I think that's the
one I think that takes me to does not
have the power to take you screw up all
right so that's all we got so far all
right so as you guys know I am you know
kind of invested into zora scales a
little bit so I figured I'd go ahead and
work on a cannonball collection that I
have are not collection but soon to be a
collection and as you guys can see here
we have 250,000 points what are we gonna
spend that all of this on you asked a
ton of scroll of redirections because
I'm gonna go ahead and do a lot of hard
clues I feel like basically what I'm
gonna go ahead and do for my cannon
collection is I'm gonna go ahead and
start off with like I think I have 1.5
maybe 2k maybe a little over I think
we're on to K cannon balls yet 2.2 and
we're gonna go to Green Dragons I'll use
all my cannon balls say or sell off the
Hyatts and bones but I'm also going to
do all the hard clues that I get there
on the side so let's go ahead and start
that up we have our clue in the bank now
and here we are hard clue cast coming in
I mean it's a unique I think so
something as simple as it is this is one
of the most frustrating many games I
feel like in the game I mean this one
was relatively nice but most games suck
and I hate coming to this place I just
now realized that there was an instant
teleport here with the game's necklace
but there we go got up to 24 Hunter kind
of knock out some of those early levels
I guess you just tried running up on me
here at a and a green dragons and yeah
we can see how that ended up for him I
don't know why he did that he decided to
do it last time too I was here Canada I
think he was also just here killing
these and he got pissed at me so he
decided to start to try to kill me and
well rip and here we go time for another
clue
ooh [__] hell yeah we got ourselves I
mean a zombie had no one cares about but
another's damn Rock page hell yeah
that's really good I wonder if it is a
duplicate of the only one that we have
so far is it okay nice nice really weird
thing but I think I always have good
luck opening caskets here
okay never mind not always a little bit
of a different scenery for this one but
time for another clue and I mean
different but nothing worth anything and
here we go going to go ahead and finish
up our falador easy test so not too bad
there we go
gonna go ahead and use this on
runecrafting as for the hard diaries I
do have to actually have to get
fifty-six so I've been meaning to get my
room crafting up for a while so that'll
motivate me one thing I'm not looking
forward though is I have to get a full
prospector outfit I have the mining
level but it's just like I know I know
how to do it oh my god I think I'm
finally done with pest control what a
time to be alive right let's go ahead go
on over here in exchange with the void
Knight please let me out of here oh my
god alright so we don't have oh god I
got to make sure you get the right helm
so we need gloves can confirm that I
know that damn well as far as helmets we
need melee and range I do believe so
we'll confirm that maybe eventually
we'll come back for a mage helm but for
the time being I do not need it so there
we go oh my god we are done reduced
stats though kind of sucks but yeah
alright here we go so the grind begins
towards getting my prospector gear so I
can do the Fowler hard diary and
something we just hit was 61 mining and
now we have the dragon pickaxe should
boost our XP per hour pretty nice pretty
nice oh my god it has been a while since
I've recorded a clip with the Zord
scales merch I don't have a lot going on
as far as the GE goes and so for now
I've just been mining finally up to 65
as you guys can see finally had the
prospector jacket gonna go ahead and be
able to get the legs here soon this
grinds coming to an end I'm gonna be
really happy once it's done but then the
problem is to still do the fairly hard
diary I still need to do I think 56
runecrafting along with rat catchers so
that's gonna be lit we interrupt your
daily dose of mining content to go ahead
and run onto the grand exchange so on my
noob account
on my noob account right now I don't
want to take any cash out of the bank
right away but I guess on my GE only
account I guess it's probably the more
proper term for it I've currently
noticed that there is a huge margin on
just you know taking varrock pieces and
putting them into sets quite strange I
understand but we're gonna go ahead and
see how much money we can make it's
pretty ridiculous out of spite of the
fact that I've been mining for the past
two days I'm gonna go ahead and sell off
the pickaxe to make room for a little
bit of coin to buy these varrock pieces
so I'm gonna go ahead and just kind of
explain what I've been saying it's a bit
weird I do not understand why this is
happening so don't bother asking I don't
think people word to you know just all
over me ready to ask why this is
happening but I'm gonna go ahead and
show you guys basically what I've been
seeing here in a second alright so yeah
in total I bought these four four one
six nine now I'm gonna go ahead and make
them into sets and see what I can sell
them on for for some reason they're
profitable I couldn't tell you I could
not tell you how or why but as you guys
can see oh my god that was better
margins than I was getting out my new
account that is insane so I went ahead
and just made about six five hundred
fifty K off of just doing that and as
you guys can see I'm just gonna go ahead
and rebuy all these another two across
the board and we will be good to go like
just look at this this is beautiful
I don't I don't get this I really
there's there's no way to explain what's
happening right now I don't know either
4.1 milligan invested sold off for four
point six I could sell these slowly but
I did tell a friend of mine about it and
as soon as people start to recognize
what's going on the margins will be no
more so I figure I'll go ahead and make
profit while I can and I'll just go
ahead and cut to the clips of me selling
them now and another two going in that's
more profit than the last you sold off
for no clue not a clue and another two
sets go to the auction block and those
old that actually didn't it didn't bring
us home a whole lot of profit that's
around 300k profit I might slowly sell
these last
two sets because I think I'm about to
hit my limit let's go ahead and see if
I'm gonna hit it oh god okay apparently
not but I think I'm gonna sell off the
final sets a little slower considering I
could actually make another two to three
hundred K if I actually wait a little
bit and there we go sold off the other
two sets this time totalling around 4.7
mil so decent profit as always gonna go
ahead and I think this has got to be my
last two right buy on another two flails
if they actually buy oh my god I guess
you can I guess you can buy twelve per
hour it seems like I'm not I don't know
god damn it
and there we go you guys don't see it
but it's right here sold off the final
two I could have bought I think another
two but the profit is relatively low I
don't know if I'm kind of being a [__]
by not buying them I don't even know if
I can buy back these two yeah I can't
cuz I accidentally sold them on cuz I'm
an idiot I don't know why I sold them
I'm dumb but I'm gonna go back to mining
now okay here we go time for you guessed
it another piece the prospector outfit
oh my god this sucks so bad give me okay
here we go there we go looking it's
debatable yeah so one of the last clips
was a clip of me thinking that I lost my
prospector legs and this clip is me
actually losing my prospector legs and
I'm done I'm done with the PvP worlds
I'm just tired of [__] going I'm just
tired of going through these [__]
Rock Falls so I decided I was gonna go
right here earlier today I [__] left
to go study for one of my accounting
tests that I have and yeah in the
[__] three minutes I was gone I got
killed like why is anyone killing anyone
here what no one's walking around with a
bank on them at motherlode mine you
[__] oh my god but yeah I didn't log
back in I've been gone for like [__]
8 hours so alright here we go so just to
go ahead and get my mind off the whole
thing I figure I'll go ahead and do
something else a little bit of content
as well I know this videos been lacking
I apologize but on the bright side I
think eclectic sar pretty low in cost
now so that should be pretty good yeah
not too shabby so we'll go ahead and get
some
damn 50 GP margin brah I never play in
full-screen so this is probably a little
different but I figure why not
and okay good start and another one I
think we're over a hundred now not
entirely sure yeah 117 Jesus but uh lit
all right well here we go time for
another chess okay cool cool alchemist
and here we go another chess another
chess pleased Rangers okay we got some
teleports close enough and here we go
another casket Jesus Christ man alright
so I've always said Ranger boots maybe
if I just say holy sandals
I'll get holy sandals nope okay last one
before I go to bed okay well well
consider to win and here we go time for
another casket okay I almost recorded
without her I almost opened it without
recording how bad would that have been
yeah you guys would have missed that
casket number 126 another one okay well
I mean that's uniques I guess oh [__]
alright well I just opened up a casket
there we go just useless stuff you know
the usual another garbage one another
chess another you combo and another a
casket and another you Sherpa another
casket okay a little different I'll wear
that though looks looks pretty hot I'd
imagine oh hell yeah
another casket more disappointment and
more disappointment and and a lot of lag
yep oh damn I didn't give any
introduction to that clip but hell yeah
we're actually getting up to a pretty
decent amount of pages if you look at
this that's actually crazy and we
actually are finally finally getting
some decent ones it's been so long but
yeah we now have to our middle pages or
three in total on Tuesday rocks so
that's really nice another one
kill me maybe a page no okay - I had him
play like see wow that's that's
something and another casket alright
anyone that does this clue please let me
know this is the captain khalid one and
this is all the way up in the Pisco
Ilias house in current like up here i
don't know how to get there quick the
only thing the only thing i can think of
is teleporting to here the house portal
and running up but there's got to be a
way quicker I do have the Zarek's
Hausman so please anyone let me know
thank you
another casket I think I'm only gonna do
probably about two more hopefully we get
something that's another honorable
blessing but second-to-last casket here
we go oh [__] hell yeah god I just
I'm so happy whenever I actually get
something from these man I don't I mean
Ranger boots I just don't even think
about those those aren't I mean no
matter how much I say it's not really in
my head I don't have that expectation
but there we go that's a unique to
uniques from that one damn last clue
scroll of the video it's only it's only
fitting alright so here we are end of
the video it's been fun it's been fun I
have to get to mining so oh wait
myself so much but as we do we're gonna
go ahead and price check what we have in
the bank now there is one big investment
that you guys are obviously maybe you
aren't and maybe you skip forward but
you're probably aware of and that is my
mass amount of silver scales that have
not gone up at all inferno just dropped
they're worth a hundred thirteen right
now I bought them all for about 116 so
I've lost four point five million I'm
technically speaking they went up to 129
and I could have sold them then but I
decided not to I still think that we can
make good profit off of it I do not want
to sell them now because I think
everyone that just had them all
stockpiled for the Inferno just sold
them all at once because it doesn't make
any sense why they would drop whenever
something releases like you do need a
blowpipe for the inferno but it is what
it is I'm gonna go ahead show you the
bank value and we will end off this
video so give me one second so here we
go if you guys wondering what client
this is this is conduit
I usually don't play on conduit just
because I like OS buddy a little better
but conduit does have this offer but
kind of it does have this bank value a
feature here so I'll go to go ahead and
calculate it real quick so as you guys
can see in the bank we have seventy
seven point three mil not too shabby now
this is where you know the real stuff
happens so seventy seven point three mil
in the bank on top of what approximately
now I'd say maybe one fourteen is around
172 mil so in total if you add on the
seventy-seven milled in the bank we're
at about 250 ml which isn't terrible I'm
not I'm not upset about that that's
actually pretty good considering we lost
like 20 mil on an arcane and we haven't
made any money on these back yet
so that'll be it for this video
hopefully you guys enjoyed if you guys
did make sure to leave a like down below
if there's anything you guys want to see
me do in the future or anything you guys
have questions about go ahead and
comment that down below if you guys
enjoyed the content subscribe and yeah
that's it for yourself wonderful day and